cuba has become the first country in the
world to vaccinate children from the age
of two against covet 19. scientists
there have come up with several vaccine
options which the government says are
highly effective the move is part of a
drive to reopen schools again
the latest phase of cuba's vaccination
rollout is underway
administering homegrown vaccines to
children as young as two
the first country in the world to do so
and the patients here say they're not
afraid of anything
despite his bravery there are concerns
that cuba's two vaccines haven't
undergone international peer review
though they have been put through
clinical trials like this
i want to get vaccinated in this trial
to help my friends from school to get
vaccinated too so they don't get
coronavirus
the government is accelerating
inoculations in a bed to get all schools
open after 18 months shut
up
i always wanted to get vaccinated i was
waiting for them to tell me when and
here i am
cuba hasn't been spared the kind of
misery that the rest of the world has
seen
half of its covid19 deaths have occurred
in the last month
recently hundreds of doctors were
recalled from abroad to help in the
fight at home
it seems to me that the ministry of
public health should have organized
itself a little better in anticipation
of this outbreak
and not make you wait so long outside a
hospital to get a bed
the increase in cases is happening all
over the place i was watching the
olympic games in japan which is 40 000
times more economic prospects than us
but it also has problems again with
covert who's responsible we don't know
whatever is to blame for the spike the
government is now betting on their
homemade vaccines providing the solution
helping to get kids back in the
classroom
despite questions remaining over safety
and efficacy
joining me now from lancaster is viral
infection and vaccine expert mohammed
munir mr munir not much is known about
these vaccines developed and widely
administered in cuba what's your
assessment of their safety and efficacy
well cuba is probably one of the only
countries in the latin america that have
started developing their own vaccine and
at the scale that they are demonstrating
their their efficacy but the major
problem really is that we have no uh
published peer review reports all of the
information about the efficacy and the
safety has been only through the press
releases and
both of these vaccines the one um swab
arena and abdallah both of them that
have been documented as effective as uh
more than 90 percent i mean to those or
three-dollar regime but none of that
report is really available so therefore
it's very difficult to assess from an
independent perspective whether those
vaccines have really gone through a
rigorous trial that to the level where
other international vaccine that has
been approved by who or other european
or american regulatory bodies so
therefore certainly there are questions
that needed to be addressed before an
independent person could make a
fair judgment
do we know anything about how the cuban
vaccines work
yes absolutely we do now because that is
the information that is publicly
available both the vaccine the abdullah
and sabrina and basically all the cities
of sabrina has been based on a subunit
adjuvanted vaccine which means that they
take the spike protein of the corona
virus and put it into the mammalian cell
or into the bacteria to harvest the
spike protein and that our vested spike
protein is mixed with adjectives such as
um tetanus oxide as an adjuvant to
induce the immune system so these are
basically the same technology as nova
wax the one us-based manufacturer which
has got approval in india at the moment
so the technology is pretty proven it's
very easy to manufacture very economical
storage is not really a problem but
again the technology itself is not until
it is really demonstrated the way it
should work
and at this point no other vaccine is
being used on toddlers
for you as an expert um do you think
it's safe to administer these shots to
to toddlers to kids as young as two
years
well that is really a big question i
mean as you know in the whole world
there is a
strong debate on going whether we need
to vaccinate that young children or not
but if we really look onto the data
out of one million infections in
children only two have died um of
proving 19 which means that the overall
risk of the over 19 infection in
children is negligible the reason that
we would like to vaccinate children is
really two for one is to avoid the long
covered um establishment in the young
children or secondly to avoid the
transmission because if the transmission
is carrying on in the younger children
that means we won't be able to lock the
transmission and therefore we won't be
able to have a handle on the pandemic so
certainly we need to vaccinate children
at that um uh level but with the with
the vaccine those are having
not going through the rigorous review
process uh globally and then using it in
two years old i think it is really too
early to say that
thank you very much that was viral
infection and vaccine expert muhammad
munir
thanks for having me
you